[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара бабалола раді що ви з нами Росія
оголосила війну західним цінностям
президент Володимир Путін веде цю війну
не танками а законами спрямованими проти
меншин
лгбтк спільнота в Росії живе під
постійною загрозою насильства та
дискримінації і немає ніякого захисту з
боку держави райдужний прапор і Прайд
паради заборонені гей так віри
стикаються з жорсткими репресіями
лгбтк спільнота в Росії змушена відійти
в Тінь так званий закон про пропаганду
гомосексуалізму криміналізує будь-яке
позитивне зображення гомосексуальних
стосунків
патріарх рпц Кирилл у своїх проповідях
засуджує одностатеві стосунки як прояв
західних цінностей які загрожують країні
Еля та Вікторія пара санкт-петербурга
відколи почалася війна в Україні
настроїв Росії стають дедалі більш
гомофобними і вони відчули що мають
діяти
бути молодим означає мріяти і планувати
світле майбутнє але коли починається
війна світ перевертається з ніг на
голову і увага переключається на
виживання в сьогоденні це реальність для
багатьох молодих людей в Україні Тимофій
і Ярослав живуть у невизначеності їхні
плани зруйновані російським вторгненням
Антон колумбет солдат який бореться за
майбутнє України більше року тому він
потрапив у нову реальність далеко від
дому та сім'ї
ми знаходимося на сході України поблизу
лінії Донецького фронту і під'їжджаємо
все ближче Всього за 15 км від
російських військ у межах досяжності
їхньої артилерії Антон коломбет чітко
усвідомлює небезпеку якщо мене поранять
або вб'ють і я не зможу більше кермувати
ви просто тікайте геть від машини
Антон і його підрозділ тут щоб захистити
цих людей
останніх із тих хто досі залишається так
близько до російських військ
Вони готуються до російського наступу та
після більш ніж року боїв сподіваються
що одного дня вони припиняться
[оплески]
не хотят мира усі хочуть миру
важко жити під цими гучними вибухами
коли не знаєш куди летить куди прилетить
і чим це все закінчиться
мають бути переговори тому що
кровопролиття - це великий гріх перед
Господом
і люди мають одуматися чим швидше тим
краще
Антон облаштував імпровізований штаб у
покинутому будинку Звідси він координує
роботу свого підрозділу і намагається
вербувати нових солдатів на фронт але це
стає дедалі складніше
люди просто втомилися ми воюємо майже
цілий рік без перерви у нас немає
ротацій Немає відпусток
фактично єдиний шанс відпочити
місяць-два - це отримати поранення
хочеш фокус папа покаже за два дні до
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії ми
зустрічалися з ним вдома у Києві тоді
він працював у ветеранській організації
був чоловіком для своєї дружини та
батьком для дворічного сина
36стирічний чоловік хвилювався що його
можуть призвати в армію якщо Росія
дійсно вторгнеться але навіть тоді він
був готовий захищати Україну якщо буде
потрібно
А який у мене власний вибір віддати сина
у рабство до росіян я не маю на увазі що
вони його буквально заберуть у рабство
Але я розумію що він жив би у зовсім
іншій країні
і я хочу якщо це все ж трапиться щоб він
знав що його батько зробив усе усе щоб
цього не сталося
це дорого йому обходиться а відтоді він
бачився з родиною всього три дні
Це нагадує мені за що ми боремося але
Звісно це дуже емоційно ти повністю
усвідомлюєш що кожен день насправді може
стати останнім
у Києві Тимофій Ярослав теж усвідомлюють
це
Але у віці 19-20 років їх також можуть
призвати в армію навіть тут у парку
небезпечно страх перед новими обстрілами
присутній завжди і скрізь
перед початком війни ніколи не думав що
я буду з собою постійно носити аптечку
Ви реально я цю аптечку з собою ношу
місяців
вісім на випадок якщо щось прилетить
поруч гуляючи парком я дивлюсь на парк і
я шукаю місць у яке я зможу сховатись
якщо я почую поряд
звук Дронів чи ракет Чи побачу їх
так жили Тимофій і Ярослав за кілька
днів до війни все було безпечно і
буденно вони грали в комп'ютерні ігри і
будували плани на майбутнє
Ярослав збирався переїжджати до Чехії в
школу менеджменту а Тимофій хотів
продовжити навчання в кіношколі відтоді
їхнє життя практично зупинилося
залишилися лише деякі онлайн заняття у
коледжі в період який буде під час війни
- це буде більше навіть не Як життя а
які існування Це дуже важко жити
абсолютно нормально думати про
завтрашній день і
взагалі про майбутнє коли ти знаєш що в
будь-який момент в твій будинок може
прилетіти може прилетіти будь-куди і все
може змінити змінитись Тимофій
намагається змиритися з втратою бабусі
мені подзвонили і сказали що через
погане освітлення на дорозі в мене збили
бабусю і вона через п'я днів померла в
лікарні просто через те що не було
електроенергії щоб
підсвічувати і її не побачив водій
повернувшись на фронт Антон розповідає
про смерть які він пережив
він не каже скільки його побратимів
загинуло але каже що багато
мої друзі наприклад загинули не просто
так вони загинули за Україну тож тепер
мій обов'язок жити і за них і боротися
за нову Україну І будувати нову Україну
Антон радить нам не затримуватися у
нього надовго російський обстріли можуть
початися будь-якої миті
молюски багаті на білок і сповнені
необхідних поживних речовин Але чи
знаєте ви що вони також корисні для
боротьби зі зміною клімату це завдяки
їхній мушлі яка поглинає шкідливий
вуглекислий газ італійський рибалка ваді
spaceanti безсумнівно задоволений тим що
організація об'єднаних націй ухвалила
договір про захист світового океану
молюски - це його хліб а також хліб
інших місцевих рибалок які щоранку
виходять у Дельту по щоб витягнути з
води свій улов Незалежно від погоди
у гору холодна 7ма година ранку а Гавань
у дельті по затягнута густим туманом
для водиса пайсанті це не полегшує
завдання
ти намагаєшся орієнтуватися Спираючись
на певні орієнтири
але такими ранками як сьогодні коли
туман який ми називаємо калігу такий
густий орієнтуватися важко і дуже важко
що його батько рибалив на адріатиці але
сьогодні вадіс збирає молюсків в онголе
де і скільки вони можуть ловити
змінюється щодня
увечері ми отримуємо повідомлення від
кооперативу в якій зоні можемо ловити
рибу
Коли можемо вирушати
коли повинні повернутися І скільки ми
можемо привести на берег
півгодини вони пливуть тихою лагуною
раптом тиша обривається
Ловці молюски з'являються з туману наче
привиди 15 сотень чоловіків і жінок
працюють у лагуні гору вадіс нарешті
досягає призначеної йому зони тут
неглибоко але холодно
Це єдиний спосіб зігріти руки коли вони
змерзли
вилов молюсків більше схожий на
фермерство на морському дні ніж на
традиційну риболовлю рибалки Горо
збирають майже 14 000 то молюсків щороку
Сьогодні ми можемо зібрати до 30 кг
вони висмоктують молюсків з піску за
допомогою спеціального пристрою вода має
температуру 6°c ідеальна для зими але в
останні роки температура зазвичай
тримається на позначці 11° зацельі зміна
клімату впливає і на дельту по
[музика]
ми спостерігаємо наслідки зміни клімату
тут коли змінюється рівень моря коли
дмитер широко або під час фаз місяця
Ми також бачимо вплив кліматичних змін
коли знаходимо рибу молюсків і крабів
яких ніколи раніше тут не бачили
Ось чому розведення молюсків важливе-
каже він щоб допомогти захистити клімат
учні складаються з карбонату кальцію
який якраз утримує вуглекислий газ
професор каферарського університету
Єлена тамбуріні авторка дослідження про
вплив молюсків на клімат воно
підтверджує аргументи рибалок-горо
коли молюски ростуть вони формують мушлю
яка накопичує вуглекислий газ
якщо зібрати кілограм молюсків то
вуглекислого газу який виділяється при
їх комерційному використанні буде
набагато менше ніж вуглекислого газу
який поглинається мушлями молюсків під
час росту Ось що вражає
у лагуні Горо рибалки вирощують десятки
видів молюсків на площі понад 10 км 7
років тому вадіс та інші рибалки
започаткували ще один екологічний проект
вирощування устриць і Середземного моря
використовуючи припливи та відпливи
ми єдині виробники устрійць в Італії
зараз відлив
і ці кошики з молодими устрицями висять
у повітрі та на сонці
коли почнеться приплив вся ця зона буде
затоплена
дуже добре
ці 2020 року
рибалки називають свої устриці золотими
Горо і продають їх найкращим шеф-кухарям
по всій Італії але понад усе вадіс
любить одну річ у своїй роботі
[музика]
Це відчуття Свободи
ти підкоряєшся припливам і відпливам
фаза місяця
ти частина цього прекрасного світу
нашого світу Дельти по
зберегти цей світ і забезпечити його
майбутнє для вадіса і рибалок Горо - це
справа всього їхнього життя
Життя в селі просте магазин на розі баби
крамниця з одягом але заберіть щось із
цього і місцеве життя порушиться саме з
цим зіткнулася громада у Великій
Британії коли почула що одна з їхніх
заповідних крамниць зачиняє свої двері
тоді Кріс Морган та інші мешканці
вирішили керувати нею самостійно у
сільському уельсі де багато людей
пристосовується до життя після брекситу
з'явилася ідея робити все власноруч
черговий звичайний день у нью-порті
у цьому уельському містечку проживає
близько тисячі людей
є чотири паби господарчий магазин
хавартс магазин працює вже майже 150
років
Але приблизно за рік після брекіту
прийшла погана новина хавартс планував
закрити свої двері це було шоком Ми всі
були спустошені Я маю на увазі що
хавартс існував у ньюпорті багато багато
років задовго до того як я приїхала сюди
це дуже старий традиційний бізнес усі
були дуже-дуже засмученими що ми його
втратимо
ніхто не хотів уявляти життя без своїх
сковорідок і приладдя для кухні тож
мешканці
ньюпорта взялися збирати майже
півмільйона фунтів стерлінгів і взяли
магазин під свій контроль тепер
працівникам допомагають волонтери такі
як Кріс Морган інженерна пенсія
ми неприбуткова організація прибуток
повертається назад після оплати витрат і
невеликої виплати відсотків акціонерам
він повертається назад у громаду
корисне джерело фінансування у важкі
часи для Британії після брекіту коштів
ЄС зараз дуже не вистачає в сільському
уельсі наприклад споруда футбольного
клубу
ньюпорті була побудована за кошти ЄС за
оцінками уельського уряду брексіт
спричинить дефіциту понад мільярд фунтів
стерлінгів протягом 5 років тому деякі
люди в регіоні перехоплюють ініціативу
очевидно що втрата європейського
фінансування стане ударом але нам
доведеться шукати інші джерела
фінансування як всередині громади так і
через уряд Уельсу та уряд Великої
Британії
у господарському магазині хавартс
місцеві жителі об'єднуються щоб
допомогти врятувати магазин волонтери
допомагають скрізь де це потрібно
Іноді вони роблять ключі або просто
спілкуються
Я люблю тут просто все роздивлятися для
чого це для чого те всілякі такі речі це
можна використовувати по-різному тут є
Все ти просто роздивляєшся навколо і
думаєш мені б не завадило щось із цього
для мене це справжній рай для шопінгу
тут завжди була дивовижна атмосфера і
мені подобається тут працювати але тепер
додаткове задоволення тому що ти
відчуваєш що робиш Це для суспільства
у ньюпорці понад 500 людей зараз
володіють акціями і допомагають зберегти
хавартс серце своєї громади західний
Уельс переважно сільський спостерігає як
молодь масово виїжджає з нього повсюди
закриваються магазини крізь томос член
благодійної Організації Що займається
розвитком громади у цьому регіоні а
вартість енергоносії призводить до того
що багато невеликих магазинів зазнають
труднощів і закриваються ми щодня бачимо
в новинах Як страждають місцеві магазини
але коли крамниця громадська ми працюємо
з більш ніж п'ятьма сотнями акціонерів
щоб заохотити їх підтримувати свої
магазини
для мешканців
ньюпорта перехоплення ініціативи
принесло свої плоди їм навіть вдалося
заручитися підтримкою Британського уряду
який планує допомогти у фінансуванні
нового кафе для податкової привабливості
міста
[музика]
тут є це ви звісно не можете цього
відчути але тут пахне парафіном мастилом
пластиковою шкірою це повертає вашу
дитинство коли такі місця процвітали А
це місце процвітає дотепер
завдяки громадській закупівлі
відчувається що люди діють у найкращий
спосіб який тільки можливий і всі це
підтримують
немає невдоволених або людей які не
згодні з тим що ми робимо
жителі ньюпорта та їхній громадський
центр хаварц стали джерелом Надії в
регіоні про проблеми якого ускладнилися
після брексіту
місцеві жителі сподіваються що їхня
громадська ініціатива принесе користь не
лише їм але й наступному поколінню
мешканців ні юпорта
[музика]
опалення будинку без газу та переживань
щодо стрімкого зростання цін на
енергоносії розкіш недоступна багатьом
європейцям але в Нідерландах рахунки за
електроенергію Еріка хохевена значно
знизилися а він живе в голландському
місті утрех де жителі проголосували за
те щоб назавжди припинити постачання
природного газу
копійка гривню береже Дякуємо що ви були
з нами сьогодні і до зустрічі наступного
тижня
українською мовою озвучено центром
медіаініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]